[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro une bonne année puisque
je l'appelle le plaisir 12,2 vous l'a
souhaité donc on est en direct c'est
figaro live et on attend vos points de
vue vos réponses à la question autrement
notamment faites vous confiance au
gouvernement pour accélérer le rythme de
la vaccination la question est en ligne
sur le site du figaro vous êtes nombreux
à avoir déjà répondu
et on posera la question ce soir à jean
louis bourlanges bonsoir jean louis
benoit bonne année députés centristes
des hauts-de-seine et face à vous alexis
brézet directeur des rédactions du
figaro bonsoir daksi le figaro qui
revenue ces dernières heures sur une sur
une info passée inaperçue la réticence
des cultes face à la nouvelle loi sur
les principes républicains la loi censée
combattre le sens de séparatisme
islamistes catholiques protestants juifs
craignent notamment qu'on accroissent le
contrôle sur ceux qui jouent le jeu de
la république sont là c'est la formule
utilisée par le représentant de la
fédération protestante alors partagez
vous ces réticences ne la partagent et
vous pas eh bien on en débat mais
d'abord ce chiffre on a dépassé les 2000
vaccination l'information a été donnée
ce matin par le ministre de la santé
il assure olivier ferrand ça accélère il
vaccination lire c'est à dire x 50 par
rapport à la semaine dernière
aujourd'hui on va augmenter d'ici jeudi
on va augmenter encore de façon très
importante
on va être sur une courbe exponentielle
rassurez-vous par rapport à cela c'est à
dire que la situation le rythme de
croisière de la vaccination en france va
rejoindre celui de nos voisins dans les
prochains jours
alors faites vous confiance au
gouvernement pour accélérer le rythme de
la vaccination c'est la question qu'on
pose sur le site du figaro pour
l'instant c'est le nom qu'ils
l'emportent en milieu d'après midi on
était à 69 2 74% et au début de cette
émission on est à 73 % de non et c'est
l'état d'esprit notamment du président
de la région ile de france xavier
bertrand qui va plus loin en critiquant
la stratégie vaccinale du gouvernement
si elle était bonne le gouvernement ne
l'aurait déjà pas changé deux fois en
moins d'une semaine
et si je viens aussi c'est à la fois
pour dire au gouvernement
changez tout dans votre stratégie mais
surtout pour commencer j'ai tout sujet
quoi relais déjà la première chose dites
nous la vérité je veux que le
gouvernement nous dise la ville qu il
dise pas la vérité
combien de doses ont été commandées
exactement par la france parce que ce
que je pense c'est que nous sommes à
nouveau face à un risque de pénurie de
vaccins
alors on est en face à un risque de
pénurie de vaccins c'est ce que nous dit
xavier bertrand s'est en tout cas sa
crainte jean louis bourlanges
vous partagez la crème de xavier
bertrand vous faites confiance à olivier
ferrand je fais je fais confiance au
gouvernement pour faire ce qui peut mais
je trouve que le gouvernement a été mais
absolument calamiteux sur le plan de la
communication de façon extrêmement grave
vous l'avez dit comment je le patchouli
si les diables miami j'ai extrêmement
grave pourquoi je crois qu'il ya eu
d'abord une erreur sur l'analyse de des
craintes supposée du peuple français je
pense qu'il ya dans ce pays
pas mal de réticences à l'idée du vaccin
il ya des antilles vague qui sont selon
moi des gens pas très raisonnable pas
très réfléchie et des gens qui veulent
se faire vacciner
le gouvernement a été pendant un premier
temps très obsédé par les premiers
essais d'imola là les gens ont peur on
va leur dire qu'on va fait ça
progressivement qu'on va lentement
c'était complètement absurde parce que
le vaccin n'est pas obligatoire donc la
communication sur ce plan elle était
simple de dire si vous avez peur du
vaccin
vous ne le faites pas point final en
revanche il était clair qu'ils auraient
une impatience très forte de la part
d'une partie très importante de la
population à barlin vous à votre micro
est tombé donc on va aller vous le
ramasse on va leur masse à tenir val
d'orné alexis s'est bien débrouillé pour
dire que je suis d'accord avec lui dans
ses prémices et à dire de dire qu'on a
surestimé les craintes qu'à mon sens
sable c'est donc aller au delà d'une
erreur de communication je pense que
c'est une erreur d'analysé donc de
stratégie car partant de cette
surestimation des craintes on a bâti une
stratégie et que cette stratégie on est
contraint dans l'urgence de la revoir de
la revoir à toute vitesse
parce qu'on se rend compte qu'elle n'est
pas adapté etc en tout cas les gens ne
la tolère pas c'est à dire que le simple
la simple vision des chiffres comparés
du nombre de vaccins qui a eu
nous comparer ce qui se passe et je ne
parle pas des états unis de la chine de
mémé de l'italie l'italie dont on nous
dit les thalys et le bazar
il n'y a pas d'état ya pas
d'administration il ya une armée
esquelbecq soit en italie et quand on en
était à 500 il en était à 120000
maintenant qu'on en est à combien il a
dit combien la différence alors ce matin
il dit 2000 vaccination yeah yeah yeah
190 donc que la france qui
s'enorgueillit de la plus belle
administration du monde de la plus belle
du plus belle machine étatique en
distribuer 500 quand les italiens en
district c'est quelque chose de deux
dossiers à fuller de ses dirigeants donc
je pense que c'est une erreur d'analysé
qui a conduit une heure de stratégie et
donc il faut changer de stratégie donc
maintenant dans l'urgence on annonce
qu'on va changer qu'on change qu'on
change
là j'espère que ça va marcher une seule
question que je me pose c'est que si on
n'a pas préparé les choses en un mot est
ce qu'on arrive à changer aussi vite que
ça de stratégie d'accord avec ça je
crois qu'il y avait deux choses il y
avait une troisième qui vient d'être
signalée par alexis à savoir que
l'administration ça ne va pas du tout
c'est tout et puis on a d'une
communication de monsieur fisher qui
était assez bizarre oui monsieur
réaction je ne suis pas l'homme de je ne
suis pas l'homme de la logistique
je suis pas bon en logistique c'est un
spectacle d'après ce qu'on me dit très
grand scientifique mais il est là pour
la logistique
le vaccin c'est pas lui qu'il fait sont
les labos ouais donc je vais finir mon
raisonnement parce que le q vous avez
entre votre micro pour y avoir fait ça
me réjouit
je disais donc qu'il y avait à mon avis
deux erreurs de stratégie la première
c'est celle là c'est d'avoir surestimé
la résistance qu'il fallait les consoles
et les concessions qu'il fallait faire
aux gens de deux lentilles vax gens qui
avaient peur alors qu'en réalité la
tante de la population était d'accéder
le plus rapidement possible aux vaccins
dont il ya eu vraiment une
incompréhension et la seconde qui est
très grave aussi c'est d'avoir fait
semblant de dire qu' il
n'y avait pas de problème de doses il
n'y avait pas de problème de
disponibilité de vaccins que c'était
donc simplement en application d'un
principe de précaution qu'on était lent
or moi je crois que la stratégie devait
être la stratégie de communication je
devais être complètement inverse
il fallait dire nous sommes de toute
manière en pénurie
nous ne sommes pas nous français nous
sommes tous en pénurie parce que on a
inventé ce vaccin en quelques mois
files heures et les autres labos et en
fabrique à tire larigot
mais on sait très bien qu'on n'arrivera
pas trait à combler dans les délais elle
enroule s'il avait dit ça il serait dit
la vérité il aurait dit qu'il faisait le
maximum pour acheter les vaccins que les
labos on pouvait pas leur en vouloir il
faisait le maximum pour en produire et
que ce serait le rang tandis que là ils
vont donner maintenant le sentiment que
si tout le monde n'est pas servi c'est à
cause de leurs propres stratégies de
mauvaise distribution
je crois vraiment que c'est un raté et
puis on à l'administration
ce qu'a dit alexis est très juste moi
depuis le début j'avais dit non on ne
peut pas au figaro mais dans l'opinion
j'avais dit quelque chose avait dit
qu'on voit dès le mois de mars l'année
dernière que l'état
il ya quelque chose qui fait très bien
c'est sa profession d'assureur
d'assureurs sociale donne de l'argent il
prend en compte et il ya un truc qui
fait très mal
ces gestionnaires et bien on voit tous
les jours qu'il est bon assureur et
qu'il est mauvais gestionnaires
soit quand on est à la convergence dans
ceux de ceux qui au départ est un fiasco
alors peut-être que nous croisons les
doigts que ça va s'arranger avec le
temps
acceptons-en l'auguré ça va demander
quand on est parti dans un mauvais sens
est dans une mauvaise pente après fonds
pourra même pour enfin bon en tout cas
ce fiasco niskala mon sens il est à la
convergence de deux travers français qui
sont là en l'occurrence là qui se révèle
catastrophique
c'est d'une part la dérive
bureaucratique que jean lui vient de
décrire la l'instant le la bureaucratie
tatillonne qui dit alors petit à petit
tu as 80 ans qu'il peut dire mieux les
bosses et d'avoir eu raison d'avoir dans
les ehpad puis ensuite dans les dents
dehors d'eux et pas depuis puis plus
clip lui faire une espèce de plante
d'une
cathédrale administrative alors qu'il
suffisait de dire les volontaires ont
léon léon les vaccine bon donc ça c'est
le premier jeu culte premier travers qui
est le dérivé administratifs
bureaucratiques et le deuxième travers
qui est là qui relève de la petite qui
la frousse qui est là la peur double
peur d'une part on surestime les
oppositions les anti vaccins on se dit
il faut les amadouer donc on va en faire
des tonnes dans la précaution ce faisant
ne fait que renforcer leurs craintes en
dedans en disant vous faut quatre jours
pour ce qu'il n'y ait plus au bout de
quatre jours d'un droit de se rétracter
comme s'il s'agissait d'un acheter un
appartement que sais-je encore donc
première crainte la loi scrivener ça ne
s'appelle pas ça c'est la première
aspects de la crète mais la deuxième
secousse et la frousse personnel
juridique des décideurs politiques qui
ont tellement peur des conséquences
judiciaires l'ensemble des décisions qui
pourraient prendre qu'ils en viennent à
ne plus prendre de décisions car le ils
se disent que le moyen de se mettre à
l'abri ces deux d'en faire le moins
possible de repousser dans le temps et
de prendre ceinture bretelles précaution
la difficulté c'est que quand on fait ça
on fait prendre des risques au lait
qu'on se protège soi même en tant que
décideurs politiques ont fait prendre
des risques majeurs
donc là on a on a ces deux c'est un peu
la poule et l'oeuf et donc c'est bleu et
quelques pas du tessin pardonnez moi
messieurs mais est ce que vous pensez
vexé ça d'abord le programme d'origine
parce que dans la bureaucratie la nuit
sinon sur l'administration s'il n'ya pas
une volonté politique derrière
est-ce que c'est pas il sait pas le
problème de ce nombre une pratique moi
je tendrais un exemple ce que me
racontait françois bayrou tout à l'heure
à pau il ya un truc de personnes un
chien ne pas qui est un foyer il ya 35 %
des gens qui sont frappés et donc le
reste qui ne l'est pas highgy bâcher les
vaccins on va les faire vacciner les
peuples ah non ah ben non parce que
c'est un foyer donc on ne vaccine pas
alors il ya 65 % qui sont les gens les
plus exposés aux alors pourquoi il ya
une bonne raison c'est que le vaccin
mais trois semaines avant de produire un
effet église
si on va on distribue les vaccins sont
là ils vont être touchés avant ça ne
servira à rien comme on n'a pas beaucoup
de vaccins on les utilise pas mais c'est
un raisonnement dingue c'est un vrai
cessez le réseau monde du cabinet de
verront d'ailleurs mais c'est un
raisonnement
parce que c'est un raisonnement qui
consiste pour économiser les doses à ne
pas à ne pas s'adresser en priorité aux
populations les plus directement menacé
est concerné donc tout ça ce sont des
biais bureaucratique mais globalement je
crois que la situation est quand même
l'attitude du gouvernement est
globalement normal il fait tout ce qui
peut alors l'administration ça ne marche
pas donc on va avoir 8 10 15 jours de
retard c'est grave quand on a des
centaines de morts
mais on va quand même y arriver à peu
près dans les temps
ce qui m'inquiète et c'est pas de la
faute du gouvernement mais il va en
prendre les le contrecoup politique à
son corps défendant si je puis dire
ce qui m'inquiète c'est la situation
dans un mois et demi quand ou dans deux
mois quand on sera à cours de vaccins
qu'on n'aura pas assez et pas parce que
le gouvernement agit mal parce que
simplement on ne produit pas
suffisamment de vaccins
hélas si on a le virus anglais parce
qu'il faut quand même voir le contexte
est essentielle on a quand même une
espèce de de situation de panique
outre-manche sur la contagiosité du
nouveau virus si on a une situation de
cet ordre en france et bien accrochez
vos ceintures
alors comment on va revenir sur le virus
anglais dans les prochaines heures je te
répondre ah bon elle et ce sera question
cette question du virus anglais c'est
vrai que la situation y est il ya cette
citation de ceux de semis panique au
royaume uni après les scientifiques
restent encore circonspects sur cette
rue on verra peu est ce qu'il ya
vraiment une forme particulièrement
virulente non pas dans la gravité de la
maladie mais dans la transmission de la
maladie qui est en train de se
développer et de prendre le pas sur les
autres formes en royaume uni c'est une
hypothèse c'est la mauvaise hypothèse
est la pire est-ce que tout bêtement au
royaume-uni brioude se rencontre qui n'a
rien fait pendant un mois un mois et
demi que tout à coup bah ça augmente
parce que ça va augmenter
et quand on ne fait rien si on ne
confirme pas du tout et c'est quand même
un peu schizo au royaume uni pendant
plus belle chose au monde de façon
exponentielle
tout à coup on se rend compte que c'est
très haut il vous trouver une raison et
on dit et on met en avant ce nouveau
variant aujourd'hui c'est pas absolument
certain que
l'augmentation de la courbe au royaume
uni sur la conséquence d'un variable
c'est peut-être tout simplement
l'inertie as asymptotique à la hausse de
2,2 de l'épidémie donc ça il faut voir
ça on verra mais enfin c'est vrai que
c'est que c'est une inquiétude c'est
évident la question de la de la pénurie
de vaccins c'est vrai qu'elle pourra se
poser à terme
après il faut voir les capacités de
production vont augmenter plus les
semaines vont passer de nouveaux vaccins
voir des autorisations astrazeneca va
l'avoir
le freezer va pouvoir augmenter ses
capacités de production donc ça peut
arriver mais ça n'est certes pas une
raison pour les économies d asseoir
dessus en disant ce protest choristes
dans mon nom me manquait dans deux mois
va pas le distribuer maintenant c'est
absurde il vaut mieux ce qu'on a on le
distribue puis le jour on en manque on
attend qu'un et d'autres séries c'est
parce qu'il faut savoir ils ne savent
pas distribuer rapidement il avait quand
même théorisé non non je pense que c'est
c'était l'erreur stratégique les
lourdeurs bureaucratiques sont
inextricablement liés mais il n'y a pas
qu'au les lourdeurs bureaucratiques
il n'y a pas que l'argent ne faut guère
plus la bataille du clash si vous étiez
bien sûr des français et des anglais
quand même une erreur d'analysé
stratégique était de se dire on va y
aller pas à pas parce qu'on va chaque
chose en son temps il faut qu'on ait
précisément qu'on économise carats
on aura l'air malin dans deux mois quand
on n'en manquera bastien ne manque de
demande
il vaut mieux vacciner les chiens tout
ce sera aujourd'hui ce qui fait peser
une autre demain si nous étions pas
justement une erreur on répète toujours
la même erreur parce que finalement
c'est l'un des aspects de la crise des
masques au début c'est on en a pas je
lui ai dit c'est pire pardon les masques
le gouvernement peut dire à bon droit
que c'est pas de sa faute si elle pas de
masque au début de l'épidémie c'était
plutôt le gouvernement davantage l oms
avait dit que l'on était pas qu ils
étaient pas obligés de nous mentir et
nous dire que c'était inutile ça pour le
coup c'est de sa responsabilité mais le
fait qu'ils manquent de masques il peut
dire c'est pas moi bon les tests le fait
l'amour d'heure de mise en page
on peut dire on n'était pas prêts on le
savait pas puis les français de toute
façon on peut pas les isoler son
élection rétif on peut rien faire
c'était déjà moins convaincant mais les
vaccins
ça fait des semaines et des mois qu'on
dit qu'à qu'une issue à cette affaire
c'est le vaccin qu'il faudra un jour ou
l'autre distribuer les vaccins qu'on
n'ait pas mis en place des
réfrigérateurs partout des centres pour
distribuer les vaccins qu'on n'est pas
dit dans tel endroit c'est un tel qu'il
est qui les distribuera tellement qu'on
n'ait pas fait ça pendant tous ces mois
toutes ces semaines ça franchement il
n'y a pas d' excuses là pour le coup
c'est c'est de pire en pire bien une
idée qui revient en boucle depuis un
mois et qui recueille l'assentiment de
toutes les nuances du centrisme mon cher
jean louis c'est pour ça que voulez-vous
la soumettre à leurs prg udi modène
je n'ai pas consulté le nouveau centre
mais c'est le passeport vers
l'obligation d'être vacciné pour aller
au cinéma ou au restaurant par exemple
est ce que vous êtes pour vous et moi je
suis extrêmement pragmatique sur cette
affaire parce que je vois la situation
où il y aura trois tiers de fa 3,3
partie de la population une partie de la
population qui ne sera pas vacciner
parce qu'elle ne voudra pas une partie
de la population qui sera vacciné et qui
est de toute manière ne sera pas menacée
si elle vit au cinéma avec des gens qui
ne sont pas qu'ils sont porteurs du
virus et une troisième catégorie de la
population qui ne sera pas vaccinés bien
qu'elles veulent
et là il faut donc faire attention à
terme je n'ai pas d'objection de
principe à ça je veux dire que je crois
que le droit de contaminer ne fait pas
partie des droits de l'homme
les anti vaccins devraient s'en est visé
1 c'est pas vous n'avez pas passé par
l'homme n'avait pas le droit de
contaminer donc je comprends très bien
qu on ait des droits particuliers
quand on est des devoirs particuliers
quand on n'est pas vacciné qui est de ne
pas se mettre dans des situations
contaminent les autres mais je crois que
tout ça c'est une affaire de travaux
pratiques et je crains que iea tiers de
la population qui soit très mal à l'aise
donc moi je regarderai ça vraiment wait
and see moi ce qui me paraît fondamental
actuellement c'est d'accélérer et
d'accélérer la production d accepter
parce que là pour l'instant on a
quelques jours de retard
c'est très spectaculaire par rapport à
israël mais ces quelques jours de retard
mais dans dans deux mois si on est dans
trois mois si on est bloqué par
l'absence de production là on sera bien
là prévu
jours et la distribution et le circuit
logistique de distribution
d'administration des magasins qui ne
cherche au tlm embryonnaires elle
commencera à marcher on est long mais
non quoi est ce qu'on a en nous inondant
des ménages par le coucher pourquoi ce
qu'on nous dit faut pas faire de
vaccinodromes parce que à l'époque de
h1n1 on en avait fait et on s'est rendu
compte qu'on aurait dû mieux faire ce
qui est une erreur parce que non pas de
l'avoir fait mais parce que la chine
allait le la vérité c'est que le virus a
disparu elle vient donc les jambes
étaient lourdes et on aurait mieux fait
de passer par les médecins généralistes
mais et donc est ce qu'on a fait donc on
n'a pas cette matinée aujourd'hui on n'a
pas de structures collectives et les
rares maires je vois je pense à la liste
hardware de deux cas de quinze jours ils
se font engueuler odeurs dont vous
n'avez pas le faire ok bon donc on n'a
pas les structures collectif mais est ce
que pour autant les médecins
généralistes ont le vaccin ils n'ont pas
non plus donc on se prive de quelque
chose alors qu'on aurait dû faire le
contraire c'est les 2 c les structures
collectives pour ceux qui ont très envie
de se vacciner ils vont ils foncent et
ensuite les médecins généralistes pour
convaincre petit à petit ce qui pourrait
avoir des réticences parce les anti pacs
mais ceux qui prêtent réticents mais là
on n'a ni l'un ni l'autre c'est moi le
vrai problème vous avez tout à fait
raison mais le vrai problème sur la
durée c'est le manque de disponibilité
prévisible de vaccins en nombre
suffisant et le gouvernement ne
l'avouent pas alors que le gouvernement
n'y est pour rien et qu'ils devraient
assumer cette situation qui est une
situation de contrainte qui lui est un
progrès comme elle nous est un projet
assez et je pense qu'elle soit il faut
enfin une est un obstacle après l'autre
la l'obstacle aujourd'hui c'est de
vacciner les gens bien donc
l'accord se dire que demain il en
manquera bombe a peut-être qu'il
manquera doigt mais déjà ce qu on a deux
millions de doses on a distribué combien
mobiliser 2002 il en reste quelques-uns
distribués dont il estime d'ailleurs je
vraiment commencé bah oui c'est un peu
le problème c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on
leur reproche
avouez que c'est bizarre non mais en
plus à andijan jeu il faut être là oui
j'aime beaucoup d'erreurs mais ça n'est
pas une course de vitesse c'est à marion
banon c'est ma passion
kundera dans le fusil à pompe à pied de
mathieu laine là-dessus mathieu laine
donc à retrouver et on va demander à
sacha bekerman de vous le mettre dans le
chat alors je vous donne la parole
chers internautes et kris kross
si christophe minute cissé pour vacciner
n'importe comment c'est pas la peine
d'accélérer
alors pour l'instant on a on n'a pas été
en tout cas confrontés au problème
je salue la note comme voilà la question
c'est qu'est-ce que vous appeliez
vacciner n'importe comment
babineau que je salue le coeur du
problème de cette campagne de
vaccination c'est la stratégie initiale
adoptée par le gouvernement ce serait
intéressant de savoir ce que vous
entendez par là et nicole 06 est
d'accord avec avoue alexis ce foutu
principe de précaution nuit à toutes les
initiatives quel que soit le sujet alors
christophe lui pense que le passeport
vert est trop compliqué à mettre en
place
effectivement peut-être que est-ce que
derrière cette idée qui est en vogue
même on n'arrive pas à mettre à mettre
en place des vaccins bon coeur on passe
déjà revendu punir les gens qui sont pas
vaccinés vaccinons ceux qui ont envie
d'être vaccinés a mal on verra oui mais
oui ça c'est un vrai ça je l'avais où il
faut produire à réprimer mais on ne
propose pas la solution
c'est comme l'idée de l'obligation on
arrive alors la question que vous posez
justement quand vous posez qu'on
continue de vous poser sur le site du
figaro c'est si vous faites confiance au
gouvernement pour accélérer le rythme de
vaccination je vais essayer de regarder
hors direct les résultats à la question
si j'y arrive
eh bien oui je vais y arriver et pour
l'instant c'est le nom qui l'emportent
cette fois ci on est redescendu action
par donc faites vous confiance au
gouvernement pour accélérer le rythme de
la vaccination va le ressentir entre
nous soit dit oui je fais confiance pour
qu'ils accélèrent mais derrière tout ça
et l'on est inerte et je crois à la
barrière physique dans quelques semaines
du nombre de vaccins c'est ça je crois
qu'il vaut pas il faut pas se tromper
quand même deux le vrai problème c'est
celui là c'est la course de vitesse
entre un virus qui devient de plus en
plus contagieux qui risquent de devenir
de plus en plus contagieux et de toute
manière une
une mise à la disposition des autorités
publiques des vaccins qui restera quand
même très très lent très très inférieur
à l'ensemble des besoins dans ce cadre
là le gouvernement a vraiment fait
lentilles communication on a bien
compris votre point de vue jean-louis
sur cette question en tous les cas 30%
des internautes qui ont répondu partage
votre point de vue est en tout cas un
partage de la confiance que vous faites
au gouvernement pour accélérer le rythme
et la vaccination
ça vous a peut-être échappé mais depuis
hier les autorités morales et les élus
sont auditionnés à l'assemblée dans le
cadre des discussions autour de la loi
sur les principes républicains
vous savez c'est la loi qui est censé
lutter contre le séparatisme islamistes
alors avant l'audition demain du recteur
de la mosquée de paris chems eddine
hafiz et du responsable du comité des
musulmans turcs de france ce sont les
autres cultes qui ont été auditionnées
ces dernières heures en particulier hier
et ils ne sont pas c'est peu de le dire
du tout emballé par cette loi
je vous propose d'abord d'écouter le
président des évêques de france
monseigneur eric de moulins beaufort
nous ne sommes pas demandeurs de ceux de
ce projet de loi
le problème majeur c'est que la 7e ce
projet doit se présente essentiellement
comme répressif qui vient ajouter des
mesures de contrôle
mais avec le risque de donner
l'impression au bout du compte que
finalement les croyait les religions et
les croyants en général les croyants en
particulier sont notre pays des gêneurs
où le président du consistoire israélite
rallye de france joël mergui va lui-même
plus loin je ne tolérerai pas je ne
tolérerai pas que le judaïsme soit le
dégât collatéral d'une règle qui
voudraient imposer qui voudrait
s'imposer pour limiter le l'islamisme
radical
donc il ne voudrait pas que judaïsme
soit une victime collatérale de cette
loi pour lutter contre l'islamisme
radical
alexis est ce que vous comprenez ses
réticences qu'est-ce qu'elles craignent
les religions les catholiques les
protestants les juifs de ski crédit
crédit pour l'amalgamme ils se disent on
est en train d'être victimes de l'
amalgame il ya un problème posé par en
france par l'islamisme radical
ils se disent on va payer pour les
musulmans radicaux et force est de
constater quand on regarde ne serait-ce
que l'intitulé de la doua que quelques
et ensembles d'éléments qui vont dans
leur sens et qu'on commence par faire
une loi contre le séparatisme islamistes
qui ont fait de loi contre les
séparatismes les roses ex-aequo à les
autres et puis une loi pour la laïcité
et donc on se dise pas 16 donc c'est
qu'il ya un problème en france entre les
religions et l'état et jusqu'à présent
on n'avait pas tellement le sentiment
que les catholiques les protestants les
juifs poser un problème quelconque et ça
finit par une loi de sur les principes
républicains et donc les catholiques les
protestants juifs dit mais pourquoi vous
nous chercher des poux pourquoi vous
voulez nous contrôler davantage
pourquoi voulez mieux plus contrôler nos
écoles jusqu'à présent il jamais eu de
problèmes avec nos écoles avec nos avec
nos cultes avec ce qui est dit dans nos
prêche
donc si vous avez un problème avec les
musulmans bon c'est vrai peut régler le
mais ne venez pas nous chercher des poux
on peut pas leur reprocher alors
jean-louis quelle position d'un homme à
la fois héritier de la démocratie
chrétienne et de ce fer de lance de la
licéité plus partir avec moi je suis
chrétien et démocrate
je ne parle pas de l'union mais c'est
comme les gaullistes de gauche
grigoli ce que je n'avais pas besoin
d'être gaullistes savait pas besoin de
deux doses pour être gaulliste devereux
et le oui moi je crois qu'il faut
replacer sa replacer ces réticences
extrêmement fortes de la part des
différentes religions notamment l'église
catholique dans l'histoire je pense que
depuis la révolution française que c'est
il faut vraiment voir ça il ya eu 3 3
attitude différente entre la religion et
et l'église il ya eu une un principe de
liberté qui a été posée très fortement
89 par mirabaud par talleyrand pardonne
ou par un certain nombre de gens qui ont
dit lalalala l'état puis la république
n'ont rien à voir avec la religion
liberté liberté condorcet aussi était
sur cette ligne et puis vous avez eu une
ligne et religieuses qui a été alors bon
le lettre i religieuses autres cas il
faut une religion c'était d'ailleurs
tiré du contrat social la religion
civile etc
donc on avait on avait un contenu
théologique et puis on avait une
troisième 3ème attitude qui a été
l'attitude concordataire qui a été celle
de napoléon kate et dia d'accord je
tolère les religions mais je contrôle
lisez anatole france
l'homme du match on voit bien comment
les les promotions des curés et des
dents au débiteur d'un public était
tenue par le bureau des cultes qui était
un bureau tenus par des francs maçons au
ministère de l'intérieur
or quand on a vraiment la préfète bonne
forme we have avant collectif
les ornements pourra faire des vins
vendus le prêtre qui joue le rôle est
extrêmement complaisant pour dès qu'il
est nommé il devient impitoyable anti
républicain ça c'est dans mes tableaux
d'artistes c'était absolument oui c'est
la suisse est absolument absolument
formidable cette affaire là mais il faut
bien comprendre que la loi de séparation
qui a été voulue de façon très libérale
par briand qui a été appliquée de façon
extrêmement peu libérale par combes et
qui dans son inspiration a en fait
arranger l'église ils ont fait des
fulminations apparente véhémente ernotte
mais en réalité ils reprenaient et là
ils ont quand même le sentiment que par
rapport à la loi de 1905
il ya toute une logique concordataire
qui se
est en place et ils se disent exactement
ce que dit alexis pourquoi ça tombe sur
nous nous sommes prises en otage par les
islamistes alors que nous nous nous
sommes de très bons de très bons
républicains ce qui n'était pas le cas
toujours ils sont les bons républicains
de puisaye depuis pas très longtemps les
catholiques
en fait ils le sont depuis deux mois ça
a été une grande lutte sous la troisième
république l'espagne social non juifs
c'est une grande histoire très
intéressante d'ailleurs et c'est quand
ils sont devenus républicains que ça
s'est très bien passé parce que quand il
avait des idées opposées
ça se passait pas très bien donc là je
crois qu'il ya ça derrière et alors se
pose effectivement la question de savoir
si une grande loi est vraiment
nécessaire ou si on ne devrait pas
masquer a toujours été mon attitude
en face des réformes bien circonscrire
les points sur lesquels le le le
mouvement le l'organisation du culte
musulman en france pose problème et
essayer de s'en tenir à cela plutôt que
de poser un problème général qui parce
qu'il est générale inquiète tout le
monde le paradoxe de cette affaire et
que tu règlement on arrivera en rien à
réguler ou à contrôler le culte musulman
l'exemple le plus récent étant cette
affaire de conseils de deux charte de la
laïcité que emmanuel macron après
françois hollande
après nicolas sarkozy s'était juré
d'obtenir parce que tous les ses
interlocuteurs que je m'enlève dit oui
on va s'entendre
on va faire une déclaration pour décorer
et puis ça marche pas ça ne marche
jamais chaque fois que sarkozy a essayé
hollande acier macron essaie d'organiser
l'islam républicain ça marche pas donc
et là ça y est ça éclate et y aura plus
de charte de la laïcité y aura plus de
charte républicaine samedi
donc de ce point de vue en question la
loi n'a rien à voir avec les deux on
essaie d'organiser des trucs on n'y
arrive pas et par ailleurs on va mettre
des contraintes sur des autres religions
avec ce paradoxe qu on nous dit que est
juste titre que la liberté religieuse
est une liberté fondamentale plus et
qu'elle doit être respectée au combien
et que les associations religieuses se
trouvait la session davantage contrôler
que les associations sportives ces
oscillations cela mais si c'est une
liberté plus importante
il est pas qui semble à contrôler
davantage d'ordre est plus libre la
liberté importante que la loi de dieu
105 impose aux associations cultuelles
des obligations plus plus strict coke
aux associations normal mais lors de la
loi 1901 mais moi je crois que les
dangers sont sont assez je crois que
s'il ya cette référence de principe
c'est que il n'aime pas qu'on se mêlent
de leurs affaires et et or ce qui me
frappe c'est quand même quand on regarde
les les anglais les américains d'autre
même les les européens c'est qu'ils ont
il trouve quand même con on y va un peu
fort avec un lit gens eux ça alors il
faut voir il ya un climat aussi ils ont
été quand même et notamment les
catholiques très échaudés par la sphère
des messes des 30 des 30 personnes dans
les trucs donc un espèce de climat
d'énervement et sans mon dossier de
déclaration notamment de maquereaux
c'est ce que dit jean louis bourlanges
une phase d'évolution de la doctrine
collectif qui inquiète quand même une
aile macron pour expliquer aux
présidences ici que en france compterait
pas les musulmans comme dans d'autres
pays comme en angleterre au royaume uni
etc il dit ah si si mais en france il
n'a rien n'à rien au dessus de l'homme
pour la république en scène rien au
dessus de l'homme mais ça s'appelle de
l'athéisme d'état si les six pour la
république ait rien du doigt les
religions disent non la république sait
on a le droit de penser quelque chose
sur loeb c'est le dieu oui faucher
foucher volo d'herbois à lyon avait
écrit devant le cimetière la mort est à
surveiller comme un aileron mais
robespierre était con mais le maquereau
là encore pour expliquer pour pour
expliquer notre attitude visé des
musulmans on vient à revenir sur un
socle de principes qui était considéré
comme acquis qui était qu'on a droit de
considérer quelque chose au dessus de
l'homme mais simplement pour respecter
les lois de la république et tout à coup
cette doctrine est en train d'évoluer et
donc les catholiques les juifs les
protestants très énervé que la révolte
est abolie 10 mai on est en train de
payer pour les autres de se prendre des
barrières alors j'avais faim avait un
moment ça m'avait frappé savait pas été
relevé il fo mo fait une gaffe il avait
écouté c'est très simple on a eu des
relations avec les avec les catholiques
avec les juifs avec les protestants ça
s'est toujours bien passé alors je crois
qu'avec les protestants sont très
remontés ce qui est vrai c'est que les
protestants ont quand même joué
également un rôle dans
1905 donc oui bien sûr ça se joue un
rôle à la fabrication la laïcité ça
c'est clair
c'est l'entourage de laure l'entourage
qui est extrêmement protestant c'est
tout à fait tout à fait tout à fait
évident tout à fait logique et est
internaute nous dit les lois sans piles
et les problèmes perdurent faute de
s'attaquer aux vrais problèmes
mais le vrai problème c'est que il ya
quelque chose qu'on a eu recours qu'on
fait semblant de croire on fait on dit
voilà la loi religieuse doit être sue
doit être inférieur à la loi de la
république
ça nous paraît vrai pas en tant que
républicain mais ça n'a jamais été vrai
quand vous êtes 4 quand vous à
catholique juif et c'est la loi du
seigneur et apporte moi ça me frappe
quand j'ai la première première pièce de
théâtre que j'ai vu de ma vie
un comédie française quand j'avais 13
ans j'ai été voir sophocle bien antigone
antigone vous inspire la loi dans un
petit godet supérieur alors donc
d'accord pourquoi ça a bien marché était
catholique
ça a bien marché qu'aux les catholiques
pour des raisons d'évolution théologique
très intéressante et réguliers ont
considéré que la démocratie
parlementaire et est compatible avec le
personnalisme et que le chrétien a
pouvait vivre pleinement sa vie de
chrétien dans le cas de la démocratie
parlementaire et donc ils ont accepté
cela mais avant c'était tendu les
acceptait de sa connerie mais la
religion catholique n'est pas
républicaine pas pu la région
protestante
c'est pas la question est donc le vrai
problème c'est qu'il faut il voter il
faut trouver il faut développer l'islam
que dix très bien le recteur de la
mosquée de paris
le vrai problème c'est de développer l'
islam libéral d'avoir un islam dans
lequel on ne renie bur le pas et on
apprend darwin mais sa limite
c'est le vrai problème c'est le poème
des musulmans oui c'est juste lorsque
les autorités de publiquement on pas
trop intéressant mais les parce que
chaque fois qu'elle s'en remettre elles
se prennent la porte dans la figure et
pour le reste faut faire respecter les
lois
à l'écouter les prêches qui a des propos
séditieux qui sont tenus on les
répriment 6 10
imam des trucs qui sont interdits palois
on l'est on l'est on les vire on les
renvoie chez eux
d'où ils viennent toujours de pays
étrangers pendant 80 % des cas ici des
mosquées sont des lieux de terrorisme on
les ferme
il faut pas commencer à changer les
religions epr écrit soi même j'avais
besoin d'un papa qui doit relier les
prêches en arabe agrumes quoi vous allez
interdit vous avez fait après autorisé
des acadiens des conférences en anglais
enfin je veux dire que les réunions
publiques avec dans une langue étrangère
c'est très difficile de dalles et compte
donc pour faire ça il faut aloi unis
font un droit très spécifiques et c'est
ce droit spécifique que craignent un peu
les les les églises mais il faut pas non
plus qu elle s'alarme c est ce qui donne
dans cette affaire là il ya les
changements je crois qu'il faut plutôt
être sceptique inquiet avec les
changements vont être très mignonne
notamment des écoles écoles hors contrat
qui inquiète qui inquiète quand même et
les juifs et les catholiques sur le les
contrôles que sous prétexte que dans ce
sont des codes écoles ou de pseudo
écoles musulmanes on enseigne d'être
l'islamisme ils se disent qu'est ce
qu'ils vont venir chercher la faute à
des prêts quand même ce qui s'enseigne
un peu partout c'est là où on voit jules
ferry avait interdit et congrégations
non mais il était un peu jacobins pas
tout à fait libérale il avait fait un
partage pour les congrégations autorisé
mais celle qu'il n'était pas sage avait
un chien vérité un problème simple oui
mais le fond c'est que dans les écoles
hors contrats sont en train de se
développer partout parce que sur fond de
crise de s'offrir dédié de l'école
publique que les écoles avec contrats
sont limitées parce que le deal
implicite qui entre l'école publique et
l'école sous contrat c'est que on ne
change pas la proportion le rapport
entre les deux donc les parents qui ont
ce c'est quand même le cas partout les
parents
le méga dans un collant bleu entravera
seul je crois que c'est une des grandes
un des grands apports de michel de break
à l'histoire de la république les locaux
les contrats d'association avec la
définition du caractère propres des
établissements c'est quand même c'est
très bien venir sauf quelques purs c'est
sympa les autres associés aujourd'hui ne
peut pas recruter de profs
donc du coup et créé des écoles
par contre là qui est problème simple
pratique comme diraient les cheveux
avant la politique c'est que croit
volontiers ne pas organiser le pont ne
pas vider l'école publique au profit de
l'école sous contrat on a décidé de
limitez d'école sous contrat donc secret
des écoles hors contrat c'est parce que
les parents cherchent la meilleure école
c'est le seul que j'ai a paru assez
contestable dans le règlement on cherche
vainement mitterrand c'est qu'il y avait
là la contestation de l'école privée et
comment chevènement a réglé le problème
intelligemment d'ailleurs en faisant un
cartel voilà thiriez il ya une
concurrence
on va faire d'un bon oeil les parts de
marché il y aura 18 % pour lancer une
enquête
et puis voilà et c'est tout les dés de
l'enseignement laïc et rassuré parce
qu'il est fois que les jeunes et donc
deux coupes de gaza va pas à l'école
hors contrat vient hubert ezin nouvel
acteur arrive sur le marché cela
s'appelle les écoles hors contrat pour
cette raison là haut on a dépassé de peu
près de temps imparti et passionnant
donc c'est pour ça qu'on vous l'a laissé
merci beaucoup de vos contributions et
merci
nicole nous dit qu'en face le grand
ménage dans les structures de l'islam et
ce sera déjà bien et bien c'est tout le
débat qui a en tous les cas en ce moment
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivis je
donne la réponse peut-être à la question
composé sur twitter est ce que vous
comprenez la réticence des cultes sur la
future loi contre le séparatisme
vous êtes plutôt l'aise dans vos
réponses qu'il faut maintenant avec 63 %
de réponses négatives mercialys me fait
pas alors merci books and away par an la
loi n'est pas contre le séparatisme
islamistes et les corps pour les
principes républicains pour l'europe 1,6
prévient et effectivement on aurait dû
mettre des guillemets de penser je joue
je plaide coupable
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivi et on
se donne rendez vous demain avec
guillaume roquette pour un nouveau
numéro de point de vue
[Musique]